there has been some evidence that's come
out
that federal law enforcement knew
about planned demonstrations at and in
the capitol on january 6th
furthermore there's been some evidence
that's come out from revolver news
notably
that law enforcement officials were
involved
actually in orchestrating some of the
events of january 6th
now this sounds like a wild crazy
conspiracy theory
the what you're telling me michael that
the fbi
may be and i'm not not claiming this was
certainly the case but there is evidence
and there are reports of it
you telling me michael that the fbi had
some hand in what was going on on
january 6th
i am yeah i am telling you that first of
all
i know that everything gets memory hold
these days when it doesn't fit the
narrative
who planted the bombs remember we were
told they discovered bombs outside of
the rnc and the dnc
who planted them we live in the age of
surveillance capitalism to use a popular
phrase we live in the age where there's
a camera
on every block there's cameras outside
of the rnc and the dnc and every other
building
the fbi was able to trace down every
single eccentric republican
who entered the capital on january 6 but
we can't trace down who planted bombs
allegedly outside of the rnc and the dnc
that's kind of weird
and and even beyond what happened on
january 6th
as buzzfeed nude news a left-wing outlet
is pointing out the
fbi very often has a role in some of
these alleged
terror attacks so notably and this is
from
from buzzfeed the conspiracy to kidnap
michigan governor gretchen whitmer do
you remember that that was a few months
ago
we were told that the radical far-right
nazi fascist republicans we're going to
go kidnap gretchen whitmer
well it turns out that the fbi
had a pretty pretty big role not just in
in executing this this action but in
planning it as well at least a dozen
confidential fbi informants reportedly
assisted the quote-unquote investigation
into
this alleged extremist group and
this is the weirdest part some of the
informants
reportedly took leading roles in
the scheme they didn't just tell the
feds what was going on with the
extremist group
they didn't even just egg other people
along
they took leading roles in the alleged
plot
to kidnap the governor of michigan to
date
this according to buzzfeed one defendant
has formally accused the government of
entrapment
arguing that the fbi assembled the key
plotters
encouraged the group's anti-government
feelings
and gave its members military-style
training
and additional defendants have said that
they plan to make similar claims when
the cases which are divided now between
federal and state courts
go to trial within the next few months
if you want to see the long history of
this sort of thing
i'd recommend you go head over to
revolver news right now they have a
great article on
five instances of the fbi in american
history
putting forward operations to encourage
acts of terrorism
because i get the fbi's legitimate role
in getting informants to thwart acts of
terrorism
but sometimes things get so far that it
seems like the cart
is leading the horse seems like the tail
is wagging
the dog this is always my view whenever
the
ku klux klan is brought up in the
mainstream media which is
frequently we're told there are all
these klansmen running around america i
strongly suspect
that roughly 99.3 percent of
self-described klansmen in america
are just fbi informants
informing on all of the other fbi
informants that i think it's a
completely
almost completely contrived phenomenon
to maintain i'm not even saying this is
through malice it might be just through
the incompetence
of the federal intelligence and law
enforcement agencies
but to maintain a boogeyman that is
almost
entirely a phantom before you accuse me
take a look at yourself that's the name
of this
entire episode you liked the clip you
liked the episode
yeah we actually do talk about eric
clapton on that show because eric
clapton is taking a firm stand
against vaccine mandates head on over
right now to the michael knowles show on
youtube you can get it on apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play myspace
xanga live journal and you can also get
my book speechless controlling words
controlling minds
see you next time